uh this is super interesting our old
friend
andrew yang who ran for the democratic
presidential nomination
this year um is already leading a poll
for new york city mayor
even though he's not running yet and
there's been a movement to draft andrew
yang to be new york city mayor he's not
yet a candidate
and among democrats meaning within the
new york city democratic mayoral primary
andrew yang is winning yang is polling
17
eric adams polling 16 everybody else at
10 or below
there's another poll from a couple weeks
ago where it was andrew yang
20 with eric adams who i believe is the
uh
council i believe he's the council
president in new york city
uh down at 14 so this is the 2021
election
uh the new york city mayoral election is
on november 2nd
2021. the primary is on june 22nd so
we're already only six months from the
new york city mayoral primary and in the
grand scheme of things that's pretty
soon it'll just be
five months once joe biden is
inaugurated
now the current new york city mayor bill
de blasio
is term limited from running again and
this upcoming election
is going to be the first one in new york
city
using ranked choice voting so there's a
bunch of very interesting things
related to this uh it's very early the
polling is basically a tie within the
margin of error in this latest poll
and andrew yang hasn't even announced
and that's exactly what makes this so
interesting without even being a
candidate merely with the rumor of being
a candidate
this early andrew yang is already doing
really well
now at the same time even though andrew
yang is not
yet running he has signaled that he is
likely to run in a few different ways
first of all there are lots of people
claiming they've been told privately
that andrew yang plans to run for new
york city mayor
second there are people saying that
andrew yang has actually decided to run
and is simply waiting for january maybe
after
joe biden's inauguration to make the
announcement but andrew yang has been
meeting with some important
new york city figures corey johnson
who's speaker of the city council
to talk about running he's hired his
advisors bradley tusk and chris coffey
who advised michael bloomberg when
michael bloomberg
ran for mayor so i think this is very
interesting for a number of different
reasons
number one andrew yang would bring up
sort of pragmatism to the office of
mayor
that bill de blasio even for
as well intentioned as he may be i i
think lacks and i think that would be a
very interesting
uh aspect you know one of the critiques
of andrew yang is that
as president andrew yang's approach of
sort of like the
uh tech ceo um
consultant technocratic approach that
it's not well suited for
the president it actually may be well
suited for new york city mayor in some
ways which we'll dig into if
indeed he he announces number two
there's going to be many people who if
andrew yang does
announce that he's running for new york
city mayor who are going to say andrew
yang's not really progressive
and there are going to be other new
yorkers
maybe not in the democratic primary but
i'm thinking of staten island
republicans who are going to say
yang is a socialist because he believes
in universal basic income which was one
of his main
uh uh sort of uh distinguishing policy
ideas
during the democratic primary so you're
going to have i mean listen it's no
different than with biden where
the the progressive left says biden's
not very progressive and the right says
biden's a socialist communist
venezuelan marxist stalinist whatever
it'll be even further exacerbated
because this is all
you know millions of people in a very
small geographical area so i think the
contrast will be very notable
and number three there's an interesting
identity story here as well andrew yang
would be only the second asian american
candidate to even run for mayor the
other was john lew
in 2013 and then number four
because andrew yang has such nationwide
name recognition
it would be very interesting to see how
beneficial that is in
a new york city race new york city mayor
is one of the least local local races
because people and companies from all
over the country even all over the world
have a vested interest a financial
interest in many cases and who is mayor
of new york city
typically for business related
considerations
what i wonder if andrew yang has thought
of and he probably has
i i would imagine he has been thinking
about it is that new york city mayor
is a job where almost no matter what you
do
you are going to have a large swath of
new yorkers furious with you about the
job that that you've done
with some very rare brief exceptions
like rudy giuliani after 9 11
new york city is so diverse politically
economically racially uh it
in all ways you know from bronx queens
the manhattan crowd even within
manhattan staten island the most
conservative part of new york city
uh there's a large swath of the
population that's almost always furious
with the new york city mayor
you are one of the most powerful local
officials in the country as new york
city mayor
you run a government larger than many
states as new york city mayor
and it comes with some horrible
realities that the mayor is always being
ripped apart
but in the end it's not that different
from being president when half the
country hates you
but geographically again the hate is in
a much smaller area and it's around all
the time
i'm sure andrew yang can handle it every
expectation is that we'll hear from him
next month
about whether or not he decides to run
and many reports that
it's a foregone conclusion that he's
running he simply is waiting to announce
so
let me know your thoughts i think it's
there were ideas of what about if he
runs for governor somewhere
uh what if andrew yang runs for senate
somewhere
but new york city mayor is very
interesting and i'd be curious to hear
your thoughts about it
and we'll have more coverage about
andrew yang's possible
nyc mayoral run and all of the stories
from today's show
on the david pakman show instagram page
find us at david pakman show
all one word on instagram and you can
find me on instagram at david.pacman
you may not have known this but when you
see me sitting here on the show
i am often wearing shirts by a company
called teddy stratford
i asked them to be a sponsor because
they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath
the buttons which actually prevents the
chest from looking weird and stretched
out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout